dear Lord Jesus my name is Ryan right uh
and I'm Jerry
we need you today Jesus because we're
gonna check out the official teaser
trailer number one for the conjuring
part DOS oh boy
okay um stars pads dick Wilson and Vera
vagina I like the first conjuring I
didn't love the first Condren but yeah
it's weird like I I sort of felt like I
was the only guy who saw in movies like
it's good yeah you know like it's good
definitely good I feel like I should
watch it again cuz I don't know like
everybody I know like really loves it I
think it has a pays homage to the style
well it's certainly right it's really
well made like oh yeah I did
alright guys drop my weed it's really
well made I mean like I everybody and
everything in that movie is on point I
just for some reason I wasn't like oh
you know just like it Warner Brothers
that's a great company yeah do you know
when the voice is gonna speak now
sometimes
you sound like you're from London sorry
guys also shots honest say things just
to you that you can only hear yes does
it feel like it's coming from inside of
you well like it's coming from behind me
like a few years what does it say it
said let's tell you what did it say that
right now
this time is person did you have great
trailers get away with a 5/10 assign the
Holy Spirit
ah haha he got his
Oh
Oh
that is so creepy
thank you oh geez man that's awesome I
mean that trailers [ __ ] awesome it
definitely has the James one stylistic
touch to it knowing the way that they
approached I mean not that you know I
don't I don't know how he works like
when he's not working with Leigh
Whannell but I know for a lot of their
movies like they would approach it with
a different you know like paying tribute
to a different movie or something or you
know taking notes from a different movie
stylistically you know the first
insidious is sort of like poltergeist in
the second one's kind of like The
Shining yeah this almost reminded me of
The Exorcist in certain moments like
yeah its inspiration from The Exorcist
good call and that looks awesome like
that looks jarring and scary yeah yeah I
mean I genuinely feel like scared right
now
there's always something about religious
stuff because I I'm not I don't like not
I really call myself Catholic or
Christian anymore I'm spiritual but
whenever I see some of that like you
know crosses turning upside down and I
think that right there just like
terrifies me I'm like Oh Catholic
upbringing here it isn't it sort of
probes it yet your foundational learning
yeah it's like I learned about this
stuff in school and that plays into also
like a sort of uh I hate to cut like
super pseudo superstition we you know
it's like people who who either do
believe in religions or you know at
least entertain the idea it's like I
know people get uneasy on those sets and
stuff like that like cause you think
like oh what if I do actually
you know something deep and I do I do
see the exorcist vibe that you're
talking about I don't think it's ever
been so direct with a James Wan film or
look the scene feels Antichrist in a lot
of ways well yeah I mean insidious has
that sure in some ways I don't know I
mean I don't really feel like like the
last like the insidious movies really
rest a religious theory just yeah kind
of acknowledge a ghost world like you
know most ghost movies aren't overly
religious yeah you know they just
acknowledge life after you know death
and a mournful what then the scene with
all the crosses and them going upside
down yeah like significant like this is
like some devil [ __ ] right here you know
oh yeah yeah cuz like the the conjuring
the first trailer kind of played up just
like the period and the haunting element
and this to me very much feels like
we're acknowledging like the Warrens are
christian like you know they are
fighting this with the power of god yeah
you know which it does I guess that is
yeah another link there I like it not
that it not that it's like making it the
point but like you're more aware of it
yeah exactly
it does feel different I like the
beginning of the trailer to whine um
when the demons like it's coming when
the kids like it's coming from inside of
me ya know like coming from behind me no
see you mmm
ing coming spelling bee contest won by
Ryan right when Lorraine Warren was
talking to the girl and then the girl
says yeah Jeb relief was the exam might
be paraphrasing I really want you to
make your own version how do you just
redo this failure like shoot you
everyone talk like Ryan Wright shooter
no talking like you but with all the
same thing that's not that was cool it's
scary because in the in the first
conjuring it was here's a family and
then here are the heroes who are gonna
come save the day which are the Warrens
this one it's like the Warrens are in
danger now too you know cuz they didn't
focus like even the marketing the first
conjuring was here's the family you
don't even see the Warrens in the first
trailer it was just the whole scene yeah
you know that [ __ ] like the fact that it
was based on and laraine's Warren's Case
Files more of like oh did you know that
like yeah like it was like a cool thing
about the movie but this is like we are
adapting their Case Files the Warrens
are a centerpiece now I imagine if they
make any more of these that'll still be
an element you know yeah baby that's a
more personal element to it and now
they're really focusing on and it makes
sense to do that I'd be kind of bummed
out if they're like here's a whole new
set of characters of the main focus and
here come in the war and Xena so I like
that the Warrens feel more like
these these guys are the ones who are in
danger now - what I mean I'm sure you
will get that stuff in this movie cuz
like you told me you have to know the
family intimately for you to care I'm
interested to see what James Wan does
differently you know like he did
insidious and then chapter 2
I feel like 60% of people who were
unsatisfied
I would reverse that I would say 60% war
and 40% work cuz it's still pretty big
chunk yes people yes that is better you
have persuaded me on my math the medical
students mathematical mind well yeah I
mean he did the second insidious so
differently than he did the first one
and I feel like the conjuring is not cuz
you know like the first insidious did
have a poltergeist vibe and while
there's still elements of that insidious
chapter 2 it felt more like domestic
violence home invasion in a way kind of
vibe you know cuz they're saying yeah
like The Shining which is mainly that
theme with some supernatural elements to
it - yeah and this one I'm interested to
see like what is the different approach
he's gonna take this time could be the
Exorcist so Maj rather you're talking
about who knows tune in next week where
Ryan and Jerry run for me the thing
about the the - insidious movies like
they do have different inspirations they
are different but the foundation of
those at least to me feels the same they
have a similar like kind of grin on
their face as they're poking at you with
the scares and the chill factor I'm not
saying he like lost the vibe like
there's insidious yeah but they they do
feel unified to me in the sense they are
both kind of funhouse rides it's just
that one of them has more poltergeist II
trappings it's just a different recive
trapping horror genres kind of switches
up and with the conjuring I get not in
quite the same sense but I do feel that
same thing for Middle East these
trailers of like these are a little more
natural and a little more the other
period piece a little more natural not
grounded but not as heightened I guess
with the characters like so they both
has to have that um foundation and then
the first one just felt like a sort of
70s a medieval-style thing and then this
one feels more like an exorcist Isle
thing this feels like his most like just
from the trailer alone the shots that
he's getting
look beautiful like I mean this this
item looks like it's his intense one
yeah it but it looks super sharp and
super beautiful and I feel like the
effects say it's I feels like James Wan
was having some successful horror films
then he did Furious 7 which made like
over a billion dollars and then now he's
back doing the conjuring too and it's
like he probably got a lot more money
for this and and the budget probably
increased a lot and I feel like they're
using that to really enhance the look I
mean he can probably yeah he could
probably make the ghost story of his
wildest dreams on on whatever they gave
me yes you know the other part he's had
an interesting career I mean if you
track it you know and this is he did the
conjuring and then he's like I'm
retiring from horror movies just Furious
7 and he's like I'm gonna do the
conjuring 2 now yeah yeah yeah things
like the step in the right direction for
redoing my career what makes me curious
as I wonder if he'll do another horror
movie after this or if he'll go back out
and do something else
he's are in Aquaman is he yeah are you
sure yeah that's what we called me is
like if he could do that sort of thing
where he goes and does like 37 then does
a horror movie then does Aquaman then
does you know some other kind of weird
little horror movie like I think that
would be cool keep both alive you know
instead of just breaking out of horror
like be able to return you know it says
based on another true story or how true
these stories actually are there I mean
you know they are like I know but it's
like I would want to see one worth like
gilts is so real like a horror movie
where I mean probably not much excited
to have but you would ever make it a
character study for that tour see I feel
like it could work though it could work
I could totally like a psychological
horror film if you did like a very
realistic scenario like this but you
know you made it a character studying
we've got some really great actors yeah
yeah I think that cool it wouldn't be
like a structured movie Patrick Wilson
used to be known for taking off his
clothes in movies being half naked or
fully nude and he hasn't been doing that
lately you know actually whatever does
he just know by you for that well dude
look at his filmography I guarantee you
you go through the list these other
shirtless underwear or naked you
proven this to me before I'm just saying
like is this a thing people share like
yeah is somebody liable to go like
notable naked actor Patrick was like I'm
sure are you the only one I'm sure other
people know I'm sure other people know
Jerry okay and I hope he gets nude in
this one he got he got kind of naked in
bone Tom huh well there you go yeah
there you go see that's he's coming back
knows what he's doing huh that is dick
Wilson and Vera uh fagina - is he's
getting hotter by the second she's like
one of them like what mid-thirties
actresses on her way to being old know
how old she is fear for me that I will
design the most offensive things I can
think oh she's 42 well milf just because
you're in everything you know yeah you
have to have a child I don't know he
does yeah let's see if she has a kid up
couple has two children Finn just like
the black guy on Star Wars and detail
above hockey who's gonna be made fun of
for her name
oh she's married to rent hockey I would
have told you had a chance so they had a
chance after uh after all these things
you didn't know but Vera Farmiga is like
[ __ ] she's very attractive in she's
very attractive
you know like it was until the departed
I was like how she's pretty when she
start having that sex scene with
DiCaprio I know she's 42 makes her even
how she wasn't 42 like 15 years ago in
the department
it's like Jennifer Aniston what is she
like 56 now I have no idea it's like of
how Jennifer Astin is real fast really
gonna listen you're really excited about
this okay so ten years ago nothing
Jennifer Astin is older than Vera
Farmiga and every movie like this the
weird thing with Jennifer Aniston is
like now every time she's in a movie
like the movie always stops for like ten
minutes for her to have like a dance
scene or sort of like the movie just
stops and goes look though she's still
hot and they're so hot you actually get
the same opportunities sure I'm a part
she should chew
no no I don't listening part mega please
don't don't that's creepy don't do this
come on Farah mega come on you don't you
don't sound like you feel comfortable
saying her name
I was jeribai Aegina Carrie once this
year again I'm very sorry Jer about my
ear my colleagues behavior so why you
make that face she said it's creepy
someone with creepy listen guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today by becoming a reject
Jerry yeah there are reasons to Jerry
yeah a couple move your views episodes
you guest stars on on the ship dank ass
dubs to podcast hosted by Jer bear look
like you're in some kind of like weird
Miami version of NPR I want to give a
shout out to all the homosexual
subscribers if you're gay I want you to
know there's nothing to be ashamed of
it's true
I like butthole pleasure - oh no yeah
feels good I just stuck your finger up
there no I rather not really big on but
never had a girl do to you no ever had a
girl look your bottle no not not big
enough but stuff well on any side of the
spectrum selling out the gays got it
made only was normal in the street
community